normand chouinard homme de théâtre on
vous retrouve justement au théâtre du
nouveau monde
vous allez présenter pour la troisième
fois une adaptation d'une élégante de
michel tremblay et d'andré gagnon oui
pour la petite histoire on en mange une
horde de commencer votre carrière
après avoir fait votre droit avec rémy
girard pour cause d'effets choix là ça
prend une dose de talent ça prend une
bonne dose d'inconscience
il sera ce on est plusieurs à l'avoir eu
à cette époque notre corps rémy et moi
quand on est décidé de se lancer
ça a pris un temps parce qu'on ne fait
pas de cours de droit rennais aussi et
puis quand on a décidé de se lancer on
sait pas si sa voix dessus marchés de
travaux conservatoires constant une
formation raconte du monde on se prépare
ton niveau or dans l'erreur on a vu
qu'on a vu mon premier souvenir de vous
c'était un samedi de rire dans le rôle
de mails mais la voilà le québec qui est
effrayant
je suis pas une blague ça c'est mou de
nous cette expression c'est à dire que
ces deux auteurs séduisant noir john
arsenault qui ont rêvé ce personnage
pour elle c'était la québécitude dans
sap une vraie expression oubliez pas qu
on est après
le premier référendum on parle pas
beaucoup du québec qu'à ce moment je
suis ambassadeur du kanak donc pour le
départ j'étais pas certain que sans le
relais je disais mais ça ne passe à
prendre un bonhomme à la reynie girafe
faire ce mot j essaie de faire fait de
la répétition veulent voir si t'es pas
content on reportera sketch une
optionnelle avec les cadeaux mais
quelque chose qui s'est allumé j'ai
pensé à jean que la brette il m'aurait
dit bon qu'en affrontant une vraie
puissance à sanaa des frappes et quand
j'étais jeune parce que c'est un
bonhomme truculent qui est ailleurs a
chanté le premier les chansons de
vigneault faut pas oublier que je brasse
camarade hollande c'est là alors c'est
sûr que ça me ça m'a tout de suite
accroché le g10 hayat est un fils en
parcourant votre curriculum vitae pour
cette entrevue le gérer a dit que le
nombre de productions vous avez réaliste
absolument époustouflant est ce que vous
considérez comme un bourreau tram j'ai
été bourg au travail
je me souviens d'une période de quelques
jours une dizaine d'années où j'étais
propriétaire de théâtre d'été avec la
salle de bains s'appelait terre des
grands chênes de kingsey falls
je jouais à l'intelligent des émissions
régulières et j'étais directeur du
conservatoire
ça c'est un bourreau de travail n'y
avait pas beaucoup beaucoup de temps à
moi et ça a duré comme une dizaine
d'années ça se calme en vieillissant ces
choses de rimbaud ont fait pas toujours
ce qui en ce moment le fonds qui ont la
belle quarantaine et puis qu'ils vont le
faire car bourbeau puis je leur souhaite
que ce soit bridier gens vont modifier
tout ça autrement pour reprendre un
autre genre de respiration ce que j'ai
fait ce que je fais c'est ainsi c'est
plus facile pour moi vous aimez
d'anguilles
oui je suis grand papa et il ya un
monsieur qu'on connait bien que c'est à
victor hugo qui parlait de l'art d'être
grand
r si je peux développer l'art d'être
grand-père j'aimerais pas mal satisfait
naissance en apporterait quelque chose
de nouveau et jeune fille dont je suis
très fier aux in china chauveau qui est
comédienne et qui a eu ce magnifique
enfant qui s'appelle maël et vous allez
voir poindre un petit peu d'émotion
parce que sept ans au fameux touche le
coeur comme infinie alors voilà je
voulais vous dire mais une norme
acheminant le colosse qui a les yeux
dans l'eau ou mauvais pour son petit
enfant je n'ai vraiment les trois ans je
suis je suis je pense que pour faire ce
métier là si vous n'avez pas une
certaine sensibilité
ça sert à rien d seront comme on dit
soit on regarde notre jardin secret mais
un moment donné en vieillissant
si c'est un avantage de vire c'est que
l'intérêt des choses importantes suprême
importante fini par s'imposer de
lui-même et pour moi c'est la famille
vous avez quitté votre famille et de la
communauté artistique promo 70 ans parce
que vous avez été hospitalisé et oui
c'est une longue convalescence 8 heures
sur la table d'opération
est ce que cette épreuve vous a fait un
peu voir la vie différemment certaines
heures et ça me permet aussi justement
d'apprécier cette famille qu'il a avec
moi ça on dit toujours jour de l'an on
dit la santé afin de vos jours avant la
fin des jo c'est une en 50 ans la alors
si je peux développer 700 t il faire
plus attention peut-être que j'étais un
peu de soutien
mais j'ai été chanceux dans ma mon
aventure puisque
je serai le fantôme du cancer qui
planait au dessus s'est pas matérialisée
de sorte que finalement c'était pas ça
que j'avais j'avais pas de cancer j'ai
pas une chimie aux prunes de radio g t
on m'a épargné la vie m'a épargné sa
mémère quand même à donner le petit
avertissement faire attention à la
nourriture père attention d'exercice
vers attention prendre les choses plus
calmement puis de surtout de s'écouter
normand chouinard pour 2020 je souhaite
la santé en devenir si mais je l'accepté
merci merci